We showed this picture already, right?
This is a picture of the tracking
of Andrew Black's daughter.
And, the first question
is what is the state?
All right.
And the state, or
the object that was to be tracked,
was a hand initialized
contour of the head.
On the left here you see
a bunch of contours.
Okay?
In fact,
there's even one that's up here,
all right?
Those contours are the contours
represented by each or
many of the particles,
the top particles, right?
And so, for example, you can
actually talk about the mean state
as being the sort of
average of the particles.
But that doesn't really
tell you what it is.
What do mean, you know,
the state of a contour?
Well, in fact, what they did is they,
they drew a contour, and they said,
because that's not a parameter,
that's a shape.
And they said,
let's represent the state of that
contour by an affine deformation, okay?
Remember affine?
Affine is, it's a three point
to three point mapping,
takes how many parameters?
It's six parameters, okay?
Translation, rotation, scale, and sheer,
depending upon how you count those,
I mean, it's six and
you can sort of divide them up any way.
So the idea is that each particle
represents a six dimensional vector.
So, by the way, that means our particles
are living in a six dimensional space,
and the bigger the,
the number of dimensions
the more particles you need to
sort of fill up that space,
in fact it doesn't grow so
nicely, does it, right?
I mean, if I go from two dimensions
to three dimensions right,
if I had a 100 particles before, if I
wanted to have the same density I would
now need a 1,000 particles, all right?
I goes ec, it grows exponentially in
terms of the number of dimensions.
So for affine we're going to need six.
And as I said,
each of the particles represents that.
Here by the way is one of the videos.
And one of the questions you might ask
is, well where do you get the dynamics?
>> Where do you get the dynamics?
>> Well,
there are a couple of things you can do.
The easiest thing to do is to cheat.
All right?
So the reason we're using dynamics here
is that the girl is jumping up and
down in front of a cluttered background.
So to keep track of where her head is,
is kind of a difficult tracking problem,
that's why we're doing all
this work to begin with,
that's why we're using particles.
But when would tracking be easy?
How about if she was jumping around
in front of a green screen, or
a white background, okay?
Or in fact, even easier, suppose you
put her in a totally black turtle neck
sweater, and you put her in front of
a black screen, kind of like that thing.
By the way, Megan doesn't let me wear
black shirts because I'll disappear.
But the point of my disappearing is all
you would see would be my floating head,
which would be kind of creepy,
but it would very easy tracking.
So you could have somebody jump
around with their floating head,
track it very easily, and
measure the dynamics.
So one way of getting dynamics
is to sort of cheat and
get it from an easier system.
And I think for a bunch of
the stuff they do in cassation,
that's what they did.
They had an easier problem.